- What would you say if I told you
that everything you've been
taught about a healthy diet
has been a lie?
(woman screaming)
Well, maybe it's not that bad,
but between nutritional
research, lobbyist groups,
and outdated science,
some really poor eating
choices have been recommended.
Let's look at how they've confused us
and examine what we
really should be eating.
Thanks to Walmart+ for
sponsoring this video.
Beoo!
The United States first
implemented dietary guidance
in 1894, and it changed constantly
because of things like the
Depression, World War rationing,
and the discovery of
vitamins and minerals.
Things didn't get firmly
established 'til 1956
when the USDA announced
the dietary guidance
known as the four basic food groups.
This became the main education tool
for American school children
for the next 36 years.
So what were they pushing people to eat?
If there are four basic food
groups, as they said in 1956,
what do you think those
four basic food groups are?
- Proteins.
- Poultry, vegetables, dessert. (chuckles)
- Protein, vegetables, fruit.
- Protein and fruits.
Oh, that's not right.
- Steak, chicken, eggs.
- How about those fruits
and vegetables, man?
The four basic food
groups were as follows:
milk, meats, fruits and
vegetables, and grains.
These foods were introduced
as part of a balanced meal,
and the recommendation was
that you eat all of these foods
every single day.
However, these recommendations
had major flaws.
For example, there was no distinction made
between refined grains, like white bread,
and whole grains, like whole wheat bread.
And it's an important one to
make because whole wheat bread
takes more energy for your
body to break it down,
therefore it doesn't
spike your blood sugar.
It doesn't spike your insulin.
These are really important factors
that affect the metabolic
state within your body.
The worst part of this guidance
is that it provided no guidance
for the proportions of how
much you should be eating.
In fact, in a single day, you
can have a well-balanced meal
with a gallon of milk, a rib-eye steak,
peanut butter and jelly
sandwich on white bread,
and a single piece of broccoli.
I don't think that's so healthy.
And kind of weird.
Well, then things then
got better. Sort of.
Over the years, the USDA had realized
there should be a bit more
nuance in how people eat,
so they introduced the
idea of proportionality.
A great move, unfortunately,
the USDA often relied
on industry experts to help craft
and approve official dietary guidance.
This influence from groups
like the dairy, corn,
and meat industry led
to dramatic messaging
surrounding the importance of things
like low fat or fat free foods
with zero recognition of the benefits
of things like healthy
fats and clean oils.
But while they suggested eating
different proportions of foods,
they didn't necessarily
recommend the right proportions.
Bread, pasta, cereal, oatmeal,
carbs on cards on carbs.
The bottom of this food pyramid
is literally all grains,
and its recommendations
were 6 to 11 servings a day.
There's only 10 servings
of oatmeal in here
and look how much it is.
I mean, look, I'm not here to demonize
a single food ingredient
because whole grains could totally be part
of a healthy diet.
The problem here is if you
look at their recommendations
and proportions, you
could literally be eating
twice as much white bread
as you do vegetables a day,
and it was permissible and
recommended by this food pyramid.
That's poor guidance.
Also, America was going through
its fat free, low fat kick,
which meant that we were demonizing fats.
Not all fats are bad, A,
and B, we also poorly understand fats.
Like, do you know the difference
between whole milk and 1%?
This is 2% milk.
What does the 2% number represents?
- 2% of how much dairy is in it?
- 2% lactaid.
- 2% reduced.
- Fat.
- The percent of fat in there.
- Exactly. So it's the
percent of fat by weight.
This is whole milk.
What percent is in whole milk?
- Just all the fat. All of it.
- 100%.
- Probably zero.
- You think this has less fat than the 2%?
- Yes.
- 10%.
- 80%, 80%.
- 100%.
- 1%.
- 50%
- 4400.
- Percent.
- 40%.
- 3 or 4%.
- You're right. That's really accurate.
How did you know?
- I'm just guessing.
- And forgetting milk for a second,
once you remove fat food
begins to taste pretty badly.
So what did we do? Threw
a ton of sugar in there.
What did that do?
Spike our insulin, spike our blood sugar,
make our waistlines get bigger.
And here we are right in the
middle of an obesity epidemic.
(image dinging)
Despite the flaws in nutritional
guidance over the years,
there has always been a strong push
for variety in your diet,
which is exactly what you can find
with a Walmart+ membership.
You see, Walmart+ membership gives you
free same day delivery of fresh groceries
from your local store.
They've got high quality ingredients
for your everyday cooking, like
organic fruits, vegetables,
prime beef, organic
chicken, and so much more.
With a Walmart+ membership,
prices are the same as
they are on the shelf.
There are no markups,
which means that you get the
same high quality fresh food
you expect from Walmart at
the most reasonable prices.
And because of these low prices,
Walmart+ is perfect for everything
from weekly meal planning
to prepping seasonal dishes.
And believe me, the
selection is excellent,
offering fresh seasonal
fruit, like these mangoes,
pineapples, cherries, and
even seedless watermelon.
Once you place an order,
specialty-trained shoppers
hand pick the freshest items
like they're shopping
for their own families.
Strawberries are picked the day
of the delivery, not before,
and you could really
taste that difference.
They don't just do fresh
food products, though.
They also deliver what
you need for your home,
for your family, like paper
towels, beauty products,
and even back to school supplies.
Look, when I tell my
patients about the benefits
of a well-rounded diet,
I often hear their struggles
of rising costs of fresh foods,
and I get it.
But one of the best parts of
having a Walmart+ membership
offering high quality
foods, fresh products
at reasonable prices and
all without hidden fees,
to me it's a win.
So click the link below to
start your free trial now.
In 2005, they came out with
some better nutritional guidance
and they gave us a pyramid to look at.
What do you take away from it?
- Oh, there's like different
categories of foods.
- I don't know what I'm
supposed to be saying
right now though.
- Do they tell you how much
of each food you should eat?
- No.
- It's confusing. (chuckles)
It seems like the further he
gets up, the less he eats.
- I don't really get it.
Get to the top, try to eat all of them.
- This is the steps he
needs to take in his diet
to reach the top.
Nope.
- Now the good part is My
Pyramid does aim to provide
some insight into proportionality,
as represented by these
colorful stripes on the pyramid,
but it stops there,
leaving you to estimate
how much more orange
there is than yellow.
It's really, really confusing.
The chaos of the My Pyramid
wasn't a total waste though,
because there was a wide
variety of foods here,
unlike the four basic food groups.
There was upwards of 40
different foods on the graphic.
In 2011, the government tossed
all the confusing guidance
from the pyramid into the trash
and introduced us the
new redesigned My Plate.
It was gonna change how we talked
and communicated about nutrition.
Unfortunately, they may
have over-corrected.
While the misguided proportions
of the pyramids were now gone,
they also pulled a complete
180 in regards to fitness.
Where'd the stairs go?
We've also introduced a new
word into our graphic: protein.
And while recognizing that
protein comes in forms
that extend beyond animal products
is no doubt an important
evolution in messaging,
there is but one fatal flaw.
Protein is a macronutrient,
not a food group.
This means that you can
get your protein portion
with hamburgers and hotdogs.
Yeah, tasty, but not an ideal
healthy source of protein.
There is something I love
about My Plate: fish.
For the first time we
actually see guidance
recommending the consumption of seafood,
and it's such a healthy food.
It contains omega-3 fatty acids.
We've actually seen evidence
of reductions in heart disease
and stroke risk.
My biggest issue with
My Plate is that it says
100% fruit juice is the
equivalent of a fruit serving.
Yeah, maybe the vitamins
and minerals are in there,
but do you know how much sugar is in here?
A can of Cola, a popular energy drinks,
some sugar cubes, fruit juice.
Which one of these four
has the most sugar?
- I would say the energy drink maybe.
- Probably the can of soda.
- Energy drink.
- Why do you say that?
- Because I drink energy drink every day
to do my job. (laughs)
- And it gives you that sugar kick?
- Yep.
- Energy drink.
- The soda.
- What if I was to tell you those two
have the lowest amount of sugar?
- [Women] Oh!
- Probably the pure sugar cubes. No?
- No.
- No?
- The fruit juice.
- You're right.
- I am.
- And I actually sometimes drink it
thinking that it's more nutrition.
- Yes, fruits contain sugar,
but they also contain fiber,
which slows the absorption of the sugar
thereby not spiking your blood sugar,
not spiking your insulin.
Drinking 100% fruit juice might get you
the vitamins and minerals,
but it's also gonna spike your sugar,
just like any other
unhealthy sugary beverage.
Folks, just eat the fruit.
In strong contrast to the
pasta extravaganza from 1992,
we finally see vegetables
dominating the plate.
While this is excellent to see,
the further guidance doesn't differentiate
between leafy, dark green
vegetables and potatoes.
As much as it breaks my heart to say so,
potatoes and french fries do not count
as your daily vegetable.
And that brings us
to what modern nutritional
guidance is today.
What should you be eating?
What should I be eating?
For that, we turn to
our friends at Harvard.
Back to the kitchen.
Here's a plate of food recommended
by Harvard's modern nutritional guidance.
We're entirely removing dairy
and swapping it out for a
healthy fat like olive oil.
But it's nice that we're
finally making the statement
that not all fats equal bad
because there are healthy fats
and they play important roles
within your body.
Creating hormones, protecting your organs,
giving you energy, and
even boosting your HDL
which is your good cholesterol.
For the record, there's nothing
wrong with having dairy.
Remember, we're not
villainizing ingredients.
It's about not having excess dairy
and not having low quality dairy.
Another great addition
to their recommendations
is good old-fashioned water.
It's important to stay hydrated,
not only for you to feel healthy,
but also to encourage your metabolic rate.
Those who are dehydrated actually
have trouble losing weight
and have lower levels of energy.
Also, as you notice,
the majority of the plate is plant-based,
fruits and vegetables,
but it's really important to get
a wide variety of vegetables
in different shapes,
colors, and even sizes.
They're focus on healthier proteins
like fish, chicken, beans,
and nuts is also really sharp
because these are all yummy options
that carry a lot of vitamins and minerals.
And finally, we get some
guidance that encourages you
to eat whole grains
rather than refined ones.
I've actually gone vegan
and keto for 30 days
and it wasn't easy, so click
on those to check it out.
And again, huge thank you to Walmart+
for sponsoring this video.
Click the link in the description
to start your free trial today.
Stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)